ukraine's president vladimir zelinski
has signed an official request for
ukraine to become a member of the
european union
immediately he says the war in ukraine
justifies fast-track membership but
joining the eu is a time-consuming
process it requires agreement from all
27 current members now in the past some
of those members have expressed
opposition to letting ukraine in i want
you to take a listen to what david
mcallister chair of the european
parliament's committee on foreign
affairs told dw news today
but today our message was ukraine is a
european nation ukraine is interested in
having a closest possible relationship
with european union ukraine wants to
join the european union and we are
standing in solidarity with ukraine
because ukrainians are not only fighting
for democracy the rule of law and their
own liberty they're also fighting for
european values which are under attack
now in kiev but until we discuss
concrete issues about starting an eu
membership accession process which will
take a longer time that's in the
meantime also focus on how we can better
integrate this country into our eu
single market and with the
uh cooperation and association agreement
of 2014 i think we have a solid legal
ground to work on this
well for more now i'm joined by theresa
fallon she is in brussels and she's the
founder and director of the think tank
center for russia-europe asia studies
it's good to have you on the program
tonight
ukraine's president
he is pushing hard for eu membership and
we know that this process is one that
takes time
um
is the situation going to accelerate the
process for ukraine or
um is it likely to ever happen at all
very impassioned speech today at the
european parliament it was short but
very even the translator uh got all
choked up but i think that
although many members of the european
parliament were moved by his words
actually i don't think it will make much
of a difference uh it's the
the traditional eastern european uh
countries are largely supporting this
but the larger member states are very
concerned and even if they gave it
something a little more realistic like a
fast track to candidate status that
takes a long time to negotiate and i
think there are deep fears about the
size of ukraine and plus you have to
remember there would be freedom of
movement and in a postcove
economic landscape this idea of labor's
jobs uh
free movement of labor and job issues a
lot of member states in the west are a
bit concerned about that yeah i mean you
know you illustrate very well the
dividing lines there
i'm wondering then
what do you think is motivating zelinski
then to push for something that is
practically
practically impossible i mean obviously
the man fears for his life
um there's an existential threat to his
government into his country is this just
a voice of of sheer desperation that is
articulating this request
i mean i think
he he's looking ahead to the future
right so he's trying to maybe use this
opportunity to fast-track ukraine
because there's a deep outpouring of
sympathy and empathy for ukraine and i
think that he's trying to tap into that
so i think
good for him
try your best and i think that as we saw
today in the parliament there were many
many people wearing ukraine shirts on
t-shirts over their suits uh with the
ukraine flag and eu written on it so i
think that there's a great deal of
sympathy for him but it takes a lot for
even i mean there are five uh countries
already on the list and they've been
added for years it takes a long time to
get the laws to match good governance
concerns about um corruption so it's not
something that can be fast-tracked at
all
yeah i mean good governance is still a a
problematic
and thorny issue
for ukraine
let's just imagine though that
there were to be some type of fast track
lane that were to be open to ukraine
how would you expect russia to react i
mean obviously this would be a another
act of provocation in the eyes of the
kremlin wouldn't it
clearly we saw back uh in 2014 uh with
the the accession of the free the
agreement between the eu and ukraine it
was a type of trade agreement that was
signed september 14 2014 and of course
this made moscow furious
clearly membership of the eu and nato
are two of the things on russia's no
list so this would actually infuriate
moscow their fear is that there would be
more westward drift of ukraine
and not in their kind of sphere of
influence so i think that this is kind
of a non-starter for russia but that's
what this war is all about isn't it
about ukraine's western um looking more
westward rather than towards russia and
teresa i've got about 30 seconds
left the russian invasion of ukraine
though it is actually producing
the opposite of what vladimir putin
wanted isn't it
it's incredible because i mean no one
would have said this before and i think
that we've seen incredible european
unity uh unheard of changes watershed
moment we've seen germany change its
position in regard to sending lethal aid
to ukraine so and more talk of european
cooperation uh and
this is a huge turning point so i think
president putin thought he could drive
wedges see divisions in in europe and in
nato but that has not happened all we've
seen is uh europe pulled together as
well as nato members
teresa fallon with the center for russia
europe asia studies in brussels teresa
is always good talking with you we
appreciate your valuable insights
tonight thank you
thank you
you